because even are you a fan of audience
participation definitely not
no well i'm too big i just get in the
way
um but i have i've ended up well i is
this audience participation i
i went to see bruce springsteen once oh
wow and um
i'm a big bruce springsteen fan and i
love the guy and it was a big stadium
show and it was 20 000 people and i
managed to get down in the front and i
didn't realize but he he kind of he
falls back into the crowd during the
show during hungry heart and he and the
fans kind of carry him on their hands
back to the stage
and so on the first night i went and i
sort of video videoed this uh and kind
of was very excited about it and i
thought well
i'd love to be one of those people that
gets to touch the great man you know and
be part of the show and so i went back
the following night i got another ticket
and i and i was so determined because i
was like i knew where he was going to be
at what time what he was going to be
wearing i thought i'm going to touch
this 70 year old man
i
and i get there and uh and i'm doing
sure enough hungry heart and he comes
out and he's and he falls back into the
crowd and he's and i sort of managed to
line up and get in line and he's coming
down and everyone's doing this and he
comes in and the boss is about to get to
me and i received the boss like that and
i start to do this but i forget again
that i'm six foot seven
so so bruce springsteen starts to go
up the person behind his regular height
and they can't reach
for receiving and so i'm holding and
there's a moment in time
when i'm taking the full weight
i'm terrified that i'm gonna drop him
and he's gonna break his neck
and he's quite a small man but he's
quite he's surprisingly heavy
have you ever moved a sofa bed
and i'm holding him like this and i'm
just thinking what would my dad do and
my dad would always say bend at the
knees
so i start sort of bending down
i'm not and he's still going hungry
for the people
behind he carries on back safely but
honestly afterwards i just remember
thinking if i had dropped the boss
and he like broke his neck and imagine
me going back to like future shows and
he's there sort of in a wheelchair on
the street
and he's just all he could just the man
in the cricket hat get rid
of ptsd you know
[Applause]
[Music]